The gender I was going to experience. If
you could change anything in your life,
would you change anything? No, of course
I knew you'd say that. Now ask me,
what'd you change? Anything?
Everything. Every single fucking thing.
Everything I got up. Do
you have any regrets? Yes.
Someone said, well, if
you change everything, you
might not be where you want.
I go, yeah, I'll roll the dice. I could
be fucking better off. You never know.
You know? I mean, well, I
learned from all my mistakes.
All of I hated every fucking
one of them. I felt terrible.
Every fucking mistake I've ever made,
but it's made me a better person.
I'm still making mistakes,
brother Mike. I make a mistake.
It's just part of being a person,
man. I thought he makes mistakes.
I tried to be a good person.
I always tried to be a good
person and [inaudible] sometimes.
How do you try?
The more fucking people misconstrued
a misunderstanding for sure.
That's what makes me want to
do bad things to people. Yeah,
like your neighbor, the guy who lost
the bra of the gravitron. I mean,
I wouldn't encourage you to say his name
on the show. No, I know that. I know.
But you know, you see how I
feel and I, and I'm a good,
I had told this guy he could cut
down trees to improve his view,
stuff like that. I was
nice. His parents loved me.
His parents said that Lenny's the
nicest guy. You won't believe me.
He's a little crazy.
But I used to let him come down
and eat the food off the trees,
everything they want. But
he's very wealthy and he's, he's very,
you know, he's born wealthy. Yeah.
That's a terrible man. That's a
terrible place to be for a man. I mean,
if I had a son,
I'd fucking kick him out of the house
and make him go fend for himself.
I really would not.
Maybe if I did that to my kid and
ended up blowing sailors at Fleetwood,
don't daddy. I mean I went
without his own money. You
mentioned a pepper. Yeah. How many,
how many peppers did you have for
you? Oh my God. I had hundreds.
Hundreds on my route. I had three routes.
Yeah. A couple of hundred a piece.
I had the Herald for awhile, did my
main staple was the globe. Right.
I did the Harold and I did the New
York times for the whole globe,
New York times and it Cambridge, Quantico
and every now and then my father
felt bad for me. He goes, yeah,
you're not going to, you're
not going to be able to do it.
You put up money and you can show get
in the car and he'd be whipping him out
the window. He showed me,
cause he worked for the Herald as a
little a type operator and he was proud of
me for working. But he goes for
three four but what are you nuts?
Do one paper like most of them, but you
can make real money if you did that.
Like I that state,
that saved me while I was doing
standup because it gave me money.
Like I didn't have to have a regular job.
Like I could get up in the morning
and I could deliver newspapers from,
you know,
5:00 AM to like 7:30 AM [inaudible]
worst job you ever had construction for
sure. Some of those
construction gigs were rough,
really rough and it depends
on the company you work for.
I worked with my buddy Jimmy lawless
and we built a wheelchair ramp for a
Knights of Columbus. Right.
And all fucking something.
I mean it wasn't even all summer. I mean
I think I quit after like three weeks,
but all that's about us
summer in the wary. Yeah,
carry cement and pressure treated
lumber. That's all I did every day.
Cement and pressure treated lumber out
in the sun and by the time five o'clock
would roll around or whatever it was when
we quit, I didn't have anything left.
I would just eat and fall asleep and
then I get up in the morning and do it
again. It, but it taught
me something like if you,
if you want to be a laborer for life,
this is what life is and this is this
a fucking tire you're going to be.
You better figure out what you want
to do with your life and get after it,
you know?
Because at the time I was probably like
18 or nine 10 and I'll never forget how
hard it was.
I 21 I went to the national
labors training center in
Hopkinton mass where they
teach you how to be a laborer, teach
you, teach you how to be a labor.
And the same thing with the cement and
the pressure treated lumber that I forgot
on your skin and made y'all [inaudible].
And from there I'd leave and I'd go to
be a life God and an afterlife. God,
I was Jana and a couple of bones,
that's all at one at one time when my dad
gets sick and I was taking care of the
family. But then I was
a short truck operator,
which was a great job. You know, they
used to have a claw on the back of a big,
big giant pickup truck, you know,
I mean one of the stars and it's swing
it out and you'd pick up the top of the,
the sewer and then you put the claim
in and you open it up and you pick up.
And I went to every bottom
and Cambridge and said,
get a lot of complaints about this
thing coming out of you saw about that.
And they go, really? Yeah, I can take it
up really well, don't you have a beer?
You don't know how many sidewalks I
pulled up forgetting to close the clinic.
Eddie sitting the sidewalk people
down again. He got a cup of for me.
They need a drink too. We'd be shit faced.
But the Porter I pulled out was cafe on
mash up. Oh my God. The shied people.
What did you do? Like what'd you do
with the whole, but until you fixed it?
Well, we'd get it.
We'd get one of those moveable
shitters and we'd put that on one side
and then we get to college and I got,
but the guys would come and then they
could, if, if you had the right crew,
they could fix that sidewalk and a
couple of hours. Wow. Just smooth it out,
you know? But Oh fuck. You
know, Massachusetts always
has fucked up sidewalks.
I mean, or, or fucked up
concrete about the way you drive.
All the asphalt's fucked up in the winter.
The highways. I first, we're gonna,
we're going to do this mile
section and sagas I, that's good.
Now we're going up to Springfield.
Leave that right. That's not finished.
How about the big dig?
How much longer did that take
you to was supposed to change?
That's one of the biggest corruption
schemes in all of the history of
construction. I know the
big dig people went to jail.
The big dig was supposed to cost one
point $8 billion and be done in seven
years.
The big dig is still not finished
and it costs $28 billion.
That's $20 billion override.
That's like, go do a dry clean.
Is it how much you cleaned? My
pinch? $12 you go back the next week,
that'd be three grants. Oh, we ran into
some problems. Everyone made money.
I was living in [inaudible]
Malden. They were working on
it. Yeah. That was in 1988 yeah,
and they still
Joe,
they put up four ton tiles with Al
glue and they thought it was gonna.
That's what happened to questioning.
Oh yeah, look, 51 million do. Oh,
so originally 51 million. Oh my God.
It's still not done. It's still not that.
How was it not done? It says
this constructed 91 to 2007 yep.
Joe. Believe me, tell me. I
drive to all the time this pods,
but that's still on open date.
It took them 15 years to open up
the tunnel to the, to the airport.
It says it's on December 31st it's
official. Boston's big dig. We'll be done.
The Washington post in 2007 okay. But
it's just still fixed. [inaudible]
the centerpiece of the big day is the
Zicam bridge was named after a guy named
Lenny Secam. Do you know who he is? No.
Okay. Nice guy. Community organizer,
philanthropist. Wonderful person.
Joe and the people in Charlestown said
he's a Jew. What? Blow that poor job.
So I swear to God, right? Let me check.
I'm a nice guy and I'm a friend
to the Jews. I married a Jew.
I was in the tribe. I know you shake,
which the fuck would be, I'll explosion.
So I'm not like Hilo macular
Jews. I love the Jews.
Very good sex. Now what happens? They,
they had eight people from
Cambridge who were against the,
uh, Lenny's,
I can bridge being there because it
cast a shadow on the child's river,
preventing the fish from being in the
river to go out to the ocean and spawn
really, first of all, anything in that
river should not be allowed to recreate.
But secondly, all a
shadow is stopping a fish.
What the fuck do you think
fish do at night? Oh, come on.
It's who said that it
was doing that? The a,
was there a real life biologists were
saying, no. Some Bay Bay Bay, ugly women,
Cambridge that we hate. Yes.
Run for president. You can
walk across it on a good day.
It's gotten any better.
You know, you don't, y'all,
I gotta tell you it really has, it
has gotten better, but you can still,
you can still see so much when people
are rowing and they will do it. That's
bad. You know Dave? Uh, well I used to
live in Newton. I used to live in Newton.
Upper falls across the street from
like a section of the river and we see
carpet. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then one day I was out there walking
around and I saw some bubbling in the
water and I watched a condom bubble up
to the surface and I realized it was a
sewer pipe that was broken.
It was leaking raw sewage right into
the fucking river. That's where it goes.
Yeah. Do you know and family
pack when you were a kid?
The groundskeeper was Joe Moni and
Joe Moni was famous because nobody but
stepped
on that grass. No one even Yaki you'll
get up. It was like a crazy man.
And since then my friend David mellow,
he's one of my dad's friends cause I,
I wanted to learn all about grass cause
I smoked it and smoking is easy and and
growing it and growing it just and
growing. But he, when he took over,
when the sewers would back up in Boston,
they would flood Fenway park and when the
water receded there'd be actually fish
flapping in the infield
and we have pictures of it.
It's what you can pull that shit up. And
how did they come from? From the river.
From the Charles river and they'd back
up and whatever's in those shores would
come out, but through
what? Port grass area. Oh,
the water would rise from where the
water would drain out of the ballpark.
It would come back in fish and fish.
There's pictures of fish flapping
on the field. The Fenway park.
I don't know how you, yeah,
you can Google go the ladder.
Ticky ticky Yuma eliminate
Sherry. Ken. Well, Devin,
David Mellon has written like eight
books online and I went to him.
John had me invited me to come up and
sit with him on my birthday one night at
Fenway park. This is years ago, 10 12
years ago. And he said to me, he says, uh,
Lenny, you want to go sit in my seats?
I said, yeah. So when he bought Fenway,
he extended the infant
seats out two more rows.
So he has TVs. I mean, it's
right next to the ball.
So I'm sitting there with him. He goes,
if you could meet anybody in the
ballpark and the organization,
who would you like to meet him at
the groundskeeper? He goes, what?
You don't want to meet
Manny? Oh, big puppy. Oh no,
I want to meet the
groundskeeper. Why? I said,
you're just had a Jimmy buffet
out. If two nights in a row,
there's not a blade out of grass. Look
at that. Good depose. Beautiful glass.
Beautiful on the wall. He gets on the
phone. David, would you come down?
So you got Mr. Clark. I go, Oh, you know
me man. I've been dying to meet you.
So we go to his office. Yeah, I leave
John and I go to the ground. Yeah, right,
right.
So then I invite him and his wife and
kids down to my place and they come down
to the vineyard. Three weeks later they
send me Lenny clock, Fenway pot, grassy.
My lawn look like Fenway park. It was
the most amazing one. It's like shit now,
but you kind of see it as
it is. This [inaudible]
like big stock seat Joe. Wow. I'm going
to cut. They were going to carve of,
you know Lenny in my, I said no,
it was when I bought it,
when I bought this property it was all
overrun and one day I was out smoking a
joint and I was picking up paper, you
know, cause I'm a land barren, you know,
and I go, Holy shit. My, what's wrong?
There's a stone wall back in my house
is surrounded by stone walls that you
couldn't even see because the tickets
and the brush was all overgrown.
The next day she must had like
eight trucks in there and they,
I have stone walls surrounded my
entire estate and you just didn't know.
Didn't know. You couldn't even see him.
Wow. Yeah. And then I added to my lawn,
you know, I had like, I
had like maybe half an acre
lawn. I got like three acres, a lawn.
That's a lot. A lot. That's a lot of lawn.
Too much work, too much
water. Who Mo's all that shit
that, that is not good with
the lawnmower. I'm not good.
That'll let me use both tools
even though I'm Silva. No.
Pilot two is for Lenny fish. Make
good fertilizer, so if they did die,
you got some, not a good reference photo,
but this is a photo of a fish on Fenway.
It's Joe's story to go with
Joe. You first day of work,
the red Sox, January, 2001 at Fenway park.
I sat down with previous 30
year heads, ground keeper,
Mr. Joe Mooney to discuss the nuances
of Fenway. Joe said, David, if it rains,
it really rains hard. The dugouts flood
because the crown in the old field,
I wasn't surprised because I'd seen
that before. Milwaukee County stadium.
He then say if it really,
really rains hard,
the antiquated city storm drains will
back up and water will come out of the
Marine manhole covers and Fenway's
Concourse and then flood the Concourse.
If it really, really, really rains hard,
the first base camera pit will fill up
with water and the fish from the Charles
river a mile away will swim through
the city drain pipes and swim into the
camera pit and then swim out onto
the field. I said, wow, Mr. Mooney.
That's wild thinking. He was pulling
my leg. I went home and told my wife,
you won't believe the stories that Mr.
Mooney tells. Fast forward to April,
Friday night before the red
Sox home opener on Monday,
the overnight forecast was for
two to three inches of rain,
so we put the tarp on the infield. When
the rain stopped early Saturday morning,
we would receive almost
three inches of rain.
I walked behind the home plate towards
the red Sox dugout to check the
conditions of the warring warning
track and I couldn't believe my eyes.
When I looked at, I saw
fish laying on the grass.
I looked around for Joe thinking,
yet put a great prank on me,
pulled a great prank on me,
but I didn't see him anywhere.
I walked over to the camera pit and
sure enough it was full of water.
I turned around and looked
towards the infield.
I saw seven more fish between the camera
pit and second base in my rush to get
the tarp off.
Now sunny skies and get ready
for my first red Sox opener.
I unfortunately threw all the fish
away. I have wished since then,
I could have saved the fish and had
them display from my office, my home,
and for Joe. But at least I
made time to take this photo.
And since then I've had it
hanging on my office wall. Joe,
one of my favorite words is
vindication. That's an indication.
Every question that you asked
me, which I couldn't, you know,
eloquently put Joe. You know, that's
why you laugh when people say, Oh,
that's, it makes the shit I'm, could
I make this shit up? That makes sense.
It makes sense though. It's so close
to the Charles river. It makes sense.
Like a mile away, right? Oh, unbelievable.
[inaudible].